[Musik]
der alexander unterwegs sie sind
diplomaten ausland praktikums myanmar
das ist eigentlich hauptstadt naypyidaw
das ist eigentlich botschaftsviertel
ziemlich ja so dass wir jetzt der ort wo
die zukünftige schweizer botschaft
stehen müsste sollte würde aber das
heißt eigentlich oder das ist jetzt nur
für die schweiz sowie muss man sich so
vorstellen dass da wo diese diese das
hohe gras ist dass damals die schweizer
botschaft steht strom und straßen 15
bord
[Musik]
dollar
erste effekte auf deutsche
diplomatie ist in der schweiz nicht
besonders beliebt man kennt böse wenn
das ich glaube ich schon
wenn man verluste erwartet
auf sie zählen wird für die nächsten
jahrzehnte
[Musik]
am flughafen buenos aires der jonas
jetzt vier wochen dauern macht sich
diplomatisch bild und endlich aus ihrer
familie
hallo
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
der fahrer vom botschafter
höchstpersönlich bringt familie evonik
[Musik]
peter jonas der schlüssel gefunden
da wollen sich ja jetzt muss nähe drei
meinung der trinkhalle und wie geht's
dir direkt rein in die wohnung
wow das ist ja der wahnsinn
wer wohnt denn hier wie viele leute
wohnen denn hier ist echt sagen ganz
anderer stil als als sonar schweiz
aber naja und bilder weiter dass auch in
sachen hartz iv erhalten dass es zur
hessen kreisspiele als gibt es auch
immer tun habe dieser war das ist eine
spezielle stehen sie doch mal runter
ist es für den dax damit das maximum
rollieren kann ja ja sofort sofort die
wahnsinn los geht's davon ist schafft
das ist wichtig für jonas der gong
diplomatique die zwei jahre
diplomatenausbildung ist ein test für
sehen die familie in der schweiz hat
katrin ein guter job bei der ausbildung
von jonas müssen ablehne
beruflich muss jetzt also auch kathrin
ihr werk finden dass die jonas die
karriere weiterverfolgen
[Musik]
vielleicht an der deutschen schule
unterrichten
[Musik]
flug in mir mal der alexandra ist
vizechef in die hauptstadt naypyidaw
sie traf its regierungsmitglied sie
waren vor ihm er sich nicht aus der vize
minister treffen mit vertretern von der
schweiz in naypyidaw unbewohnten peter
ist eigentlich sie 14 hauptstadt von der
regierung ist wenig da der plan ist dass
irgendwann out botschafter dezent aber
jetzt sich mit einer ziemlich einsam
[Musik]
verrußt sicht ist das irgendwann mal
wirklich so viel david loosli oder ob es
einfach mal
ja ich sage punktemäßig auf ein riesiges
straße ist gigantismus
und jetzt gott aus regierung strafe das
wichtige ist auf höchster ebene wie
möglich die wichtigen gespräche zu haben
und die substanz und die messages
platzieren können
da alexander sprach mit dem hochrangige
regierungsmitglieder alexandra
erst frauen wichtig sie für das gab die
informationen zu bekommen
gern beschenken
nicht nur dass man davon sondern auch
ebenso zu sehen wie das funktioniert mit
der vize-minister ist übrigens zwei
minute später wirklich und trafen mit
der schweiz
es geht wieder zurück in die größte
stadt nach yang gon
der alexander ist für 15 bis vor kurzem
handy in myanmar in fribourg morgen über
90 prozent für die menschen die kinder
lesen und schreiben
[Musik]
frauen von meiner arbeitskollegen zeigte
alexander wütz statt
und das zum beispiel sind alles verkocht
das kommt ein regionales in den bock
nicht rein
es ist total lecker das auto wie das
über die privatbank
[Musik]
[Applaus]
als triebfeder das sympathisch glüht
sind sehr spielfreudig abkühlung
das ist viel sagt field music award ist
nicht so prestigeträchtig unter
diplomaten gehört das land nico zu den
top-destinationen sofortigen roth gehört
dazu wenn sich 4 2 alexander für den
berufsweg entschieden
[Musik]
man muss eben immer wieder geduld und
geduld und geduld und verständnis haben
dass die anderen einen nicht verstehen
können und das oft nicht einfach ist
noch so viel über die kultur und damit
schlag ist am ersten tag für mich nur
einfach aber richtig sieht das ganz
anders
der vorgang
[Musik]
schweiz braucht diplomaten will die
schweiz das mit abstand am
globalisierten land ist vor der
weltmusik constantin wirtschaftliche
politische und sonstige bezüge und die
man dann auch konstant gut geregelt
werden dass ich frage vom überleben für
das land das mir ebenso die idee das
netz unterhalten weltweit
[Musik]
senegal ich nur vor 60 jahren
französische kolonie zieht kurz zu der
stabilste startet afrika
[Musik]
jean baptiste darunter der ss island
praktikum angefangen hat ist honig
botschafter in rom das war
besichtigungstermin macht zeigt jean
baptist vor allem klassische expert
honig
[Musik]
damit ziehen
was mache ich ein riesiger ordnung so
allein mit frage wie
der nec stiefel
das schwimmbad ab doch nicht so viele
besucher
[Musik]
ist mein zuhause sind die leuchten oder
die menschen und hier habe ich noch kein
netzwerk ich gehe noch niemandem
[Musik]
der sohn behauptet sich kurz vor seiner
partnerin trend eigentlich ein 12
zusammen auf seine ziele
[Musik]
heute im 2018 januar 2018 stelle mich
gerne familie fach und denn es kommt
dann kommt es ist kein großes thema
bewusst nicht bewusst nicht
[Musik]
eine ganz andere punkte die ausbildung
ist samir sich immer nur die schweiz vor
dramatisch ihre tochter alleine auf dem
auto
die zwei jahre diplomatenausbildung
dorfsanierung mehr als fünf monate
unterbrechen aber schon briketts islam
praktikum und samira schaaf wieder 100
prozent hoffen wir eigentlich gedacht
war
konzentriert und es wird sie der
gymnastik
[Musik]
forsch dringt sehr millionen angelo mit
in der region rund um buenos aires fiel
lüthi hat europäische wurzeln auf der
residenz vor der schweizer botschaft ist
jonas hubbühne künstler land stabil
zusammen mit teamchef im botschaft
transport viele den authentischen wissen
wir es ist nicht fällt aber ist gut
naja ich glaube wir haben alles in
ordnung
darüber hat die die klasse von der
schweiz vertritt residenz vor der
schweizer botschaft
nachher möchte ich dass es nicht gut
vorgestellt und um die gäste am tisch
bevor man beginnt mit einem hinter
messen
auch willkommen heißen namen der
botschaft ich begrüße dass wir damals
[Musik]
und dan und die erstickt die geräte von
jonas auf spanisch ganz herzlich
willkommen
vor allem die schweizer künstler
verbindet damals la vida amico ging
kollege schon senior ambassador muchas
gracias
falls der potentat erstes major titel
auf deutsche mutters gracias proteste
optimiert
gero agierte sehr leid ambiente so es
besser
karin organisator lindower website
kontext toquero daniela mascali die bmw
group
ich glaube einfach gut der war nicht zu
lang dass das ist eine wichtige
voraussetzung nächstes mal wäre es noch
besser wäre kein papier in der hand
hätte
ein erster erfolg für jonas sie dort
bezogen
ob dies legt unterdessen die dritte liga
und die die ich es jetzt
[Musik]
sowohl
denn aus sicht ist wahnsinn natürlich
das liegt am arbeiten ist super aber sie
ist einfach gemütlicher weißt du die
warmen farben und so es gibt zwei
ziemlich und sie sind du willst einfach
mehr zu hause als die andere mit fünf
zimmern war riesig
[Musik]
bundesrat johann schneider-ammann es dem
klingt schmitt den schweizer bauern
grund ist schneider ammanns freizügiger
haltung gegenüber dem freihandel und
genau um diesen freihandel um ein
freihandelsabkommen ist es in den
letzten tagen gegangen es war ein
freundlicher empfang im außenministerium
im bonner cyrus und dass der empfang vom
damalige wirtschaftsminister so
freundlich sich für tausende jonas und
seine botschaft kolleginnen und kollegen
ganz viel messerscharfe die größte
herausforderung ist es nicht vergessen
also diese große delegation und da muss
man wirklich einige parallel event im
hopfen so eine bundesrats psychisches
organisatorisches großprojekt jede
minute china auf geplant und jedes wort
muss sitzen
die jonas hätte der ansprache von johann
schneider ammann mit geschafft
natürlich selbst hören wenn man
inhaltlich fordert ethik macht und das
big direkt haut und man erkennt was
dafür elemente
das ist wirklich sehr gut und das spiel
sicher dass es für die ökonomische lage
zeugen
das gegenseitige verständnis der jonas
hauptverantwortlich dafür dass der
bundesrat immer zur richtigen zeit am
richtigen ort ist
[Musik]
aber sehr guten kontakt der jonas lehrte
perfekte gab es ganz wichtige aufgabe im
diplomatischen dienst
seit der vorbereitung aber ich muss auch
sagen solche anlässe solche besucher
kommen nur zustande mit erfolg wenn man
auf einem guten team erzählen kann und
glücklicherweise ist der bundesrat eine
fünfköpfige delegation ist gut
[Musik]
dort wohnt christina sieht nun mit macht
sie ihres ausland praktikums new york
normal ist das wirklich letzte krise mit
trinken
aber ich sage heute ich bin natürlich
schon okay was kommt und das mit mir
machen und so christina schaufelt new
york die uno mission
sie vertritt schweiz im so genannten
fünften ausschuss das budget und
management verantwortlich mit musi
vertreter verschiedener länder davor
bezüge als pilotprojekt unterstützen wo
sich dafür stark macht
[Musik]
schwitzt das mir finde aber wie die uno
chef der kategorie dass die akteure
müsse zugang haben
die de versonnen beschwerdestelle frage
stellt die moz christina und die
zentralbahn besprach mit britta wer
schon mal mit denen du bitte sind 34 das
bild dieser zeit zu verschieben und dann
wirklich gut wenn diese bitte bitte ihre
zum zmittag
[Musik]
am uno-hauptsitz christine mussten
vertreter von der anderer länder klar
machen was der sinn von einem
pilotprojekt tisch und das wiener off
die der diplomatie kurze sogenannte
informelle treffen
so hat
mit kamel sorgt in der wir sehen ist im
budget
sie hat eine extrem skeptisch das ist
einfach fakt ist aber es ist ja zum
kurzum zum musikspiel war ganz groß
[Musik]
mai bei kurzweilige also jeder muss
zurück um mit der e-gitarre mit trotz
stadträte aber jetzt auf gutem weg das
mannschaft nicht ganz
[Musik]
samira zwei wochen
jetzt kommt speedy kraus vom 28
sie will die junge familie unterstütze
wenn samira ab morgen wieder 100 prozent
schafft ganztag der edgar wallace bevor
sie in eine berufliche projekt wieder
betreuen aber vor allem übernimmt eine
jetzt hat freund wickie hasn't been to
move to cairo things change
ich bin immer auf knapp drei wochen
aber dem süden der metropole
er habe ich der beste einstieg aber doch
[Musik]
christina bespricht pilotprojekt der
beschwerdestelle uno jetzt mit ihrer
chefin es kurz feedback ist wichtig dass
christina diplomatenausbildung
pilotprojekt justizsystem wirtschaft und
management verhandelt das thema
verhandeln wichtig sind und das macht
sie sehr gut
ich schlafe
[Musik]
[Applaus]
familiären erst die offizielle termin
der stadtkreis der heimat
[Musik]
also ich bleibe mir treu und wo sie
schon vorher
[Musik]
was noch für berufstätige arbeitet für
diplomatie gott lass uns nichts machen
der stellvertretende missionschefin
rauris ob mondes amira geschäftsmodell
ort beurteilen ob er denn dieses problem
aus
ja
[Musik]
in zamalek
wenn die sneaker mond will starker staat
ist überzeugt mit und yahoo
der start geht diplomatie schnittblume
die zahl stunde fahrt sanierungspolitik
auf der botschaft qriocity bestehe in
der nächsten folge von der junge
diplomaten
[Musik]